[Music]
[Applause]
so you may have seen my interview with
Jason Silva that happened at a fast
volley and what we want to do is for
behind the scenes just for you guys to
ask Jason some deeper questions and to
have our mind blown
with the mind of Jason Silva
[Music]
on stage you said something that I
thought was extremely brave when
somebody asked you you know you're such
an optimist for everything that's
happening the world right now you're
such a proponent for transhumanism an
exponential technological change and you
even said that technology will cure some
of the biggest things we have that's
happening in the world such as global
warming but you said the one thing that
worries you is nationalism yeah why is
the question why you know I grew up in
Venezuela which for many years was a
prosperous nation one of the richest
nations if not the origination in South
America giant middle-class just a model
a place that the way around the world
wanted to move to and you know granted
bad policies in that country eventually
led to social inequality that was
unsustainable and then Hugo Chavez got
elected feeding on the frustration of
the people is a kind of Robin Hood Ian
figure that would take from the rich and
give to the poor but but his fervor is
his rhetoric that is the vitriol was
that kind of hyper nationalism and this
kind of like the world and like screw
building bridges and it's all about like
us and what we're gonna do and we're a
sovereign nation and we're don't care
about anybody else and it was just like
it was ugly and it was angry and it has
like a crippled Venezuela and you know
he's dead now and his successor is much
worse is even worse even worse and the
hyperinflation and the you know if
people think that there were there was
poor people or suffering and Venezuela
before like now people are starving you
know what I mean like now people can't
get medicines the situation is totally
horrible and it is it carries the the
signature nationalist now I see where
that came from I knew you were
Venezuelan American somehow I never made
that connection yeah right now live that
directly I was like literally finishing
high school so two questions over there
because this is a fascinating topic Fox
News said I just was watching this thing
on Fox News Fox News said I mean if we
can really call it news that it wasn't
nationalism
it was socialism and Bernie Sanders is
gonna get us there your thoughts well I
think the problem is that these terms
hijacked four particular agendas you
know I think if you look at the model in
Cuba that is a totalitarian regime that
curtails the press and holds people down
and has like secret Gestapo police if
you're deaf you dissent in any way and
they call that like a socialist
revolution and you know Hugo Chavez
totally took that from Castro and we're
like the socialist revolution you know
but but that's very different than like
you know the socialist capitalist
democracies like the Netherlands or
Scandinavia you personally think that
the Netherlands is one of the most
successful countries in the world I
spend so much time in the extra dime and
I love that they are highly egalitarian
right it also highly educated that they
have complete freedom of the press and
that they have rule of law and that they
have a capitalist engine but then you
know people pay their taxes agree
education free health care of the
highest order perfect that's what I
wanted to bring up yeah right because a
lot of Americans confuse socialism with
social democracy socialism derived from
communism which is Venezuela which is
Cuba is horrible my wife's
family grew up in Soviet Russia we had
family members murdered by the Soviets
land taken away horrible but
Estonia today which is where my wife's
family is from as in Denmark as in
Norway have some of the highest
standards of living in the world and
that is social democracy yeah yeah
excellent
but now while yet now I get that
nationalism thing yeah now let's get on
to to a more positive note sure being a
wonder junkie now you describe yourself
as a wonder junkie yeah explain to us
what this is sure and what can we learn
from that so I'm a big fan of Carl Sagan
the famous astronomer and he used to
contemplate space and time on a scale
just shy of the infinite and there was
poetry in his contemplation you could
tell that the guy was was drunk on aw
his the way that he articulated both the
sublime and mystery of the cosmos in our
desire to understand such a mystery
resonated with me to no end one of my
favorite films growing up was contact
and that was Robert Zemeckis film based
on a novel that Carl Sagan wrote called
contact so he was the original novelist
behind what I think
one of the best science fiction stories
of all time and in the novel he was
describing the Ellie Arroway character
who Jodie Foster played in the film and
he described her as a wonder junkie when
trying to capture the essence of that
fire in the belly that faint disquiet
that insatiable curiosity with which he
probed at the infinity of the cosmos
like when she looked at the stars when
she contemplated space and time it
Hatchett ated her soul you know there
was this this this this ecstatic
question-asking and and he referred to
as a wonder junkie which is a strong
word right because you think of a junkie
you think of heroin addict but so
essentially he was saying well that's
kind of what it is it's like you're
addicted the way a heroin addict is
addicted to heroin but you're addicted
to wonder and and I mean that spoke to
me so much that I felt like finally
somebody gets me you know I found myself
reflected in that phrase and there's
another phrase that speaks directly to
that thirst as well it's in line by f
scott Fitzgerald that I might have
referenced in my speech f scott
Fitzgerald was this was from an essay
called the death of aw in the age of
awesome and and so the author was enry
wise Meyer was quoting f scott
Fitzgerald from a line where he was
describing Dutch sailors discovering the
new world for the first time so this
notion of seeing the fresh green breasts
of new world and the line was man must
have held his breath compelled into an
aesthetic contemplation in either
understood nor desired face to face
perhaps for the last time in history
with something could measure it to his
capacity for wonder and so it's like
something could measure his capacity for
wonder because jaded Ness or cynicism
well Michael Pollan calls the bin
there's and seen that of the adult mind
that assumption that we've seen it all
before that nothing really impresses us
that we don't really have to engage with
anything because we know what that is so
we can dispense with what's happening at
leapfrog to the conclusion being there
done that so to speak which is such a
contemporary thing these days he says
that that comes from a lack of an
experiential
that thrusts you back into the mystery
again you know that you can have an
experience when you're cracked open that
is finally kamesha it with your capacity
for wonder and part of one of my demons
I think is that I'm terrified of
becoming jaded you know for me like
existential despair is to think that
okay that's all there is and there's
nothing else and there's no more awe and
there's just resignation and so I'm
addicted to I think novelty I'm addicted
to new experiences to new ideas you know
under store to newer forms of
understanding and and and I work really
hard to seek out experiences that better
can measure it to my capacity for one
there's very big that seems like a
really remarkable way to live life now
doesn't that doe get you in situations
where you're freaking frustrated because
there isn't enough wonder happening in
your life doesn't it make it hard to
settle in one city or yes
stick to one job or one relationship yes
yes I think that's actually one of the
hardest things I think that in my own
life I remember living in Los Angeles
for five years working as a television
presenter and you know I was living the
dream I'm in Los Angeles I'm point of
parties in the hills I'm meeting
celebrities and baiting actresses like
life was good until that was all there
was until it became so familiar and they
say familiarity dedenne's you know
routine makes everything stale at least
it tends to and that has to do with
something called hedonic adaptation so
things that give us pleasure eventually
don't give us as much pleasure it's why
people who do cocaine report never being
able to get the same high they got the
first time I wouldn't know I've never
done cocaine but um but this notion of
hedonic adaptation speaks to me very
much because I think it can happen in
every context things that give pleasure
just don't give as much pleasure once
you adapt to them once they you
normalize to them and so you have to
shake things up in your own life now not
all of us are lucky enough to travel the
world you know to be exposed to
different people but but you can be
exposed to different books you know you
can go down different rabbit holes on
the internet you can take a different
commute to work you can take up a
different hobby
anything that thrusts you into a new
world you know and sometimes it doesn't
even mean that you'll find what you're
looking for but that the search is
enough
um I think it was Walker Percy who who
wrote this line that from the moviegoer
that I love he says the search is what
anyone would undertake if they were not
sunk in the everydayness of their own
lives and just to become aware of the
possibility of the search just the
possibility of the search is to be on to
something
and not to be on to something is to be
in despair so I mean I'm sure that
resonates with you too because sometimes
it's just the possibility like what's
what's beyond beyond that corner you
know what's over there Who am I gonna
meet tomorrow what new email is gonna
come in you know and and organizing my
life so that surprises consistently
arrived has been very important to me
that's amazing and it puts you in this
perpetual state of showing and gratitude
and anything but beautiful wishes to
live in the question with the questions
and to be constantly seeking you know so
I want to talk about states of flow
right you and I are big fans of Steven
Kotler and wise and you have mutual
friends and you spoke about to flow a
lot when you've only stage what is this
state of consciousness to you yeah so
the father of flow so to speak is a guy
called csikszentmihalyi most people
can't pronounce his name but Kotler
taught me therefore does the agent send
me I wrote a book called beyond boredom
and anxiety and typically human beings
oscillate between these states of
boredom and or anxiety or even like
depression the point is like we're
anxious about the future or melancholic
for the past and and that's like this
constant FRIB relation especially now
it's acute this 21st century normal like
are so nervous don't feel so much
pressure but there are these moments in
our lives where everything aligns where
things run smoothly when we lose
ourselves in an experience when we lose
track of time it can happen you know the
jazz musician when he's in the pocket
you know the athlete when he's in the
zone the writer when it comes through
him but not from him and though it is
with him it belongs not to him I mean
you feel there's an artist at least like
a conduit to something larger than
yourself and and he's this particular
experience this state of consciousness
that is defined as flow is one in which
you feel your best and you
your best and it seems to emerge under
all these different conditions people
have different triggers there are
different contexts in which this
particular flavor of consciousness
emerges and and researchers and authors
like Steven Kotler and his organization
the flow Genome Project have pioneered
some of the research into this space
they're building on the work of
Csikszentmihalyi and as it turns out
when people are in flow again not only
do they feel their best not only do they
perform their best but like
existentially it puts them in the right
space because they're not so concerned
about the future anymore in fact they're
living in a deep state of eternity now
and one of the big bumper stickers in
the age of yoga and meditation is
learning to be more present and I get
that and I think like for me to be in
flow is to be present because to be in
flow shuts down the part of the brain
that measures the passing of time so you
literally are in what Cutler calls the
forever box
you know when the athlete is in the zone
when the surfer is riding that wave time
no longer exists right and you also lose
the inner chatter so one of the
hallmarks of flow is that the inner
Woody Allen the inner critic which is
apparently controlled by the
dorsolateral prefrontal cortex that
shuts down people think they use more of
their brain in a flow a actually you
lose less the aperture focuses as Jamie
wheel says and so the inner chatter
dissipates you have this quiet stillness
the sense of time disappears so you're
in eternity now right and then there's
this feeling of like information
richness and effortlessness that's also
transpiring so you don't feel the labor
of your actions even though your
performance level is through the roof
and the amount of information you have
access to is saw smooth it's this
constant stream of new interpretable
information and there's actually a
neuroscientist who I listen to a podcast
on and he was saying that human beings
should be best described not as
carnivores or herbivores but as Infowars
because we're only ever truly happy when
we're eating new interpretable
information which is one of the
hallmarks of flow more access to more
information but notice he says
interpretable right it has to be the
sweet spot between chaos and order
because too much information if you're
flooded with too much data you become
overwhelmed you wipe out you fall off
the wave you're
underwater but if you have too little
information the water is flat you're
bored your mind starts ruminating about
the future or the past but perfect flow
is the perfect wave and it toes the line
between chaos an order it's access to
new interpretable information and that's
where we are are happiest because we are
Infowars damn I can't believe that that
entire nugget of knowledge just streamed
at me
thank you for sure you've got asked this
question like a hundred times
yeah I think what is that just your
brain connecting in the way Jason
syllabus broken so I've done some
research I'm trying to explain what
happens to me when I get wrapped up in
explaining ideas and first of all what
I've learned is I'm an associational
thinker so I learned by association you
know and there's a line by a guy called
Isaiah Berlin called to understand is to
perceive patterns so connecting the dots
and associational thinking's for me at
least is how I wrap my head around
things and what typically happens is and
this is probably because for me flow is
again Tony the line between chaos and
order so flow is the intersection
between discipline and surrender
so like too much discipline is
oppressive and too much surrender is
chaotic when both are tensely balanced
you're in flow and so I would say that
for me these ideas you know they're
coming at me right and the discipline
part that urge to explain the urge to
language the urge to encapsulate is the
part of me that's a control freak is the
part of me that's highly disciplined
that wants to make order out of chaos
but the part that invites exposure to
new ideas the part the part that avoids
dogma the part that is willing to
question everything I thought I knew the
part that invites disorder is me
bringing a little bit of cognitive
dissonance because that's where all the
new information comes in from and so
it's both you know I know a lot of
people that tell me Jason just let go
all that I just surrender you know but
if I just surrender I wouldn't have the
camera with me in the moment where the
ideas are coming through you know
obviously I'm getting out of my head for
all this inspiration to happen
but I'm also highly disciplined the
cameras charged the cameras there I've
been I'm with the right person and when
the download is happening it's like hit
record on that and I sense that you do
something very similar you know I've
noticed you in flow I've noticed the way
you run the conference but I also see
the machinations behind the scenes that
are so highly disciplined even the fact
that during this conversation you still
have the wherewithal to be like don't
forget about that camera so I think that
we're actually very similar right right
and what I appreciate about what you
just said which is so beautiful and I
wish I'd explained it as well as you
just did I was recently on impact theory
with tom bill you right and Thomas a
friend cause great - a debate I love Tom
yeah and the debate was Thomas is a
proponent of hard work I'm a proponent
of flow right and we were debating as
friends is it hard work or is it flow
and I was talking about Michael singers
ideas of surrender and you just worded
it perfectly it is the it is the
midpoint between discipline and
surrender a hundred percent now you
would love this Venn diagram that my
friend made my friend makes these
t-shirts from the imaginary foundation
and you should probably do like to get
that image and use it for some
MindValley promotion were wearing on say
so the one I was wearing is a science
and art and so Venn diagram and the
intersect and wonder what science wonder
our justice so he has this other one
that's discipline surrender and they
overlap and flow amazing amazing so so
when I interviewed Steven Kotler yeah in
in Peter Diamandis s book bold Peter
Diamandis tries to take Cutlass list and
dissect it into thirteen different
triggers of flow okay right now when I
interviewed Steven Kotler he gave me
five triggers and it seems that the
number of triggers the flow of ways of
to get into flow are constantly adapting
and changing and there's sometimes
disagreement among the herpe book sure
how do you how do you personally get in
flow so one of the most consistent
triggers for me is novelty so like
literally I mean I grew up in Venezuela
I went to an international school so my
friends were from all over the world so
I was constantly exposed to people from
different customs people who spoke
different languages people from
different backgrounds and it made me
interested in finding both commonality
between us
but also celebrating our quirky and
alien differences like all the ways in
which we were not the same and so in a
way that was a formative privilege for
me that I was exposed some novelty in
terms of how people thought how people
acted the cultures they belonged to I
used to I used to do a lot of extreme
sports growing up I mean not too extreme
but my dad was really into motocross so
you have novelty access to novelty puts
me into flow flow follows focus it's a
novel experience of course you focus on
them because they're new when an
environment is familiar you're only
going to notice what doesn't fit the new
piece of information so novelty does it
because flow follows focus extreme
sports like motocross or anything that
has a little bit of risk also focuses
you have no choice you're deeply
embodied in the activity because if you
don't you're gonna fall off the bike you
know it slow follows focus so I would
say for me novelty and a little bit of
risk now the risk doesn't just mean
physical it can be cognitive
intellectual aesthetic sometimes getting
onstage state you know that that is a
high-stakes game you're responsible for
delivering content to five hundred or a
thousand people and you better know your
stuff people feel adrenalin before going
on stage people fear public speaking
more than anything in the world but I
think it's because they're
misinterpreting what's happening you
feel adrenaline because that's your body
preparing you for ultimate performance
and people call adrenaline fear but if
you just reframe it and you're like no
that's your that's your talent that's
like your body preparing you for action
for performance you know so yeah
anything that raises the stakes
anything that throws me into novelty and
I guess this is related to novelty
aesthetically relevant experiences so so
movie watching is a huge flow inducer
for me now I'm somebody who has often an
active mind and and sometimes I get a
little bit of bandwidth anxiety where I
have trouble deciding what's the most
and what's the thing that deserves my
attention the most in a particular
moment because I want to pay attention
to the thing that is the most important
thing for me to pay attention to like I
really want to be judicious in where I
place my attention and I think what
good cinema is that it's it's it's like
it's like trusting a good restaurant or
you know in a good chef I'm like I'm in
your hands but for me the experience of
submitting to the work of a great
director it's like I'm gonna sit in the
dark and I'm submitting completely you
know I'm literally resigning myself and
I'm in his hands it's a trust fall you
know and and that also gives me flow and
people who love control like I do people
who are highly disciplined need to make
sure that they have access to
experiences in which they can do trust
Falls I think that because I have this
relationship between discipline and
surrender and and when they meet I'm in
flow but I still have a predisposition
more towards discipline and however
thinking and planning and wanting to
plan and wanting to control things and
that has served me well as long as I
found I find safe outlets for surrender
so bring in all the discipline all the
preparation up until the moment in which
it's time to let go
all right perfection is not just about
control it's also about letting go but
it's not just about letting go either
you know I mean it is toning that line
and something that's really interesting
was this study that was published I
think by the folks at Imperial College
of London on the relationship between
mental health and the entropic states of
the brain so when we can get into this
if you like but you know now there's
this whole thing happening where we're
having an epidemic of mental distress
you know anxiety and depression or going
through the roof incidences of suicide
are really high and one of these things
that this that this article was saying
is that the diseases of depression and
anxiety
stem from a brain that has become overly
ordered like to ordered so if you think
of the ego as the organizing
autobiographical mind the organizing the
chief executive of the brain it's like
the CEO has become a dictator and a
terrible tyrant as David Foster Wallace
used to describe it and so an overly
active default mode Network which is the
seat of the ego in the brain and it can
be overly active either from trauma or
from certain experiences that have made
you
so then you're like this like a brain
that has become too ordered is more
subject to the pathologies of excessive
rumination and self-consciousness that
characterize depression and anxiety it's
what people that get like loop being
obsessive thoughts and they get like
stuck in this like wiring you know and
so one of the ways to treat this these
illnesses in some of the most compelling
research now happening with psychedelic
psychotherapy and so on has been
described as an experience that shakes
the snowglobe
so if you have these grooves that have
men have like gotten so cemented in your
brain and you have these looping
patterns and you're thinking and
obsessive thinking in the rumination of
anxiety depression that you need an
experience that shakes the snowglobe
so that all of those like carved grooves
of thought like dissolve and then it's
like okay I get to be reset it's like
you're defragmenting the hard drive and
so anyway it's interesting this
relationship between chaos and order
playing out at that level so too much
order is depression and anxiety
conversely too much disorder are the
personality disorders of bipolar
schizophrenia and those that when the
brain is too disorganized wow that's a
remarkable way of explaining it yeah now
let's talk about altered states sure cuz
Cortland speaks about better oh yeah
yeah about how we live in a more of
basic society
okay indigenous cultures are polyphasic
mmm-hmm and then I see you when I see
you go on a jason silva riff mmm when
you get on stage even when you answer a
question here are you accessing any type
of alpha-theta
mmm-hmm i don't know how out at state
it's possible um i've definitely the
most compelling alter states experience
that I have had has wasn't has been
mediated by cannabis you know which has
now been largely normalized and
legalized in California but cannabis is
an interesting substance it's been used
for millennia for medicinal purposes and
also for spiritual purposes and
spiritual purposes is just a stand-in
word for an altered state of
consciousness something that changes the
way you see the world connects you
seemingly with something larger than
yourself and so people just label that
spiritual you know
but I'm interested in what's going on
what are the mechanisms of that altered
state of perception like why is that
happening
flow Genome Project research if that
caller has done talks about the four
forces of ecstasy psychology technology
neurobiology and pharmacology so
psychology is having an essence of like
how your brain works and how it's gonna
react in certain situations and what are
your triggers and so on and so forth
technology might be like you know
putting like a little thing attached to
your brain that's reading your
brainwaves so you can get feedback of
how your brain is acting situates
neurobiology is understanding like the
neurotransmitters in a dopamine and my
norepinephrine and and and the flow
cycles and how these neurotransmitters
metabolize and when is the optimum time
to for them to flood your system and so
on and so forth but the last one is
pharmacology pharmacology we're
essentially talking about drugs we're
talking about substances that are
outside that we take in and they
interact with our brain chemistry and in
doing so they change our perception of
the world and they also change how we
process information and one of the
hallmarks of cannabis intoxication is
that it's marvelous for associations
it's marvelous for associational
thinking and it has a rich history of
being used in improvisational arts jazz
musicians freestyle raps creative
artists of all types writers anything
that requires you to imaginatively
connect one concept to the next whether
it's one melody that becomes the next
melody or whether it's a freestyle
rapper that's like going off on some
rhymes and all he's getting his triggers
from the person like throw him a word
they throw him a phrase and then he's
just as it's like a butterfly effect and
thought its associational thinking it's
this concept forging a link between this
concept and that concept and how they
are related you're you're synthesizing
and you're finding through lines in
various ideas and doing that is an
organizing principle of making sense of
things I believe and I think that I
think we all have that to a certain
degree and I think something like
cannabis what it does is it expands your
associative net so it gives you an
experience of that associational
thinking that's broadened right it's
like an eye tell is a ssin of your
thoughts
and and I think that you can learn from
that experience that alters the
experience and the insights of how that
works is something that your brain I
think can remember so that even when
you're not high on cannabis that is a
muscle that has now been exercised you
know once a mind is stretched by a new
idea it never returns to its original
position so it is my view that the
practiced encounter with altered states
in a context that has intentionality
like okay how am I gonna I like like
like these studies that were done in the
60s where engineers were given LSD and
then in a context of problem solving
they were like you know bring a problem
that's been bothering you at the office
that you really can't seem to solve and
then they put them in this comfortable
living room like environment that give
them a little bit of LSD and they'd have
them work on the problem that's been
bothering them so they set up a context
for it you know it wasn't like oh go
have a spiritual experience or go talk
to God this was like no no bring an
engineering problem take a little bit of
LSD and then work on the engineering
problem you know and the point is that
the altered perception the increased
associational thinking the heightened
pattern-recognition the boosting of the
lateral thinking all these things that
Cutler talks about that's like I just
think it's a muscle that then gets
exercised you know and I don't think
that people have to be taking these
substances all the time I think it's
just it's one way of just again yeah in
gendering a capacity to think about
things in a certain way or it deploy in
a certain way of thinking when you
engage with the world and engage with
problems that's what I love how you
explained that pigs in closing whatever
your final piece of advice to the world
my final piece of advice to the world so
one can live in
live in all yeah yeah I think you know
what I don't believe in fatalism so no
matter how dark things get for each and
every one of us and we all will have our
dark night of the soul my piece of
advice to people is remember that things
can get better that every problem has a
solution that when things are dark and
when things are bloody it's not that
we're that the end is near necessarily
but that the beginning is near that I
like the even metaphor of the birth
canal sometimes the most difficult
moments the most bottleneck moments the
moments when we can't breathe might just
be the birth canal you might just be
that chrysalis about to turn into a
butterfly we might just we have to
remember we might just be able to push
through the darkness and arrive at the
other side of fear which is where
everything we wanted is you know the
cave you fear holds the treasure you
seek said Joseph Campbell and so my
advice is to try to remember that and
lean into that amazing Thank You Jay
thank you that was awesome beautiful
thank you
you
[Music]